ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi tenteremo
di fare una cosa che è passato ho fatto
quando collaboravo ancora con cucina da
uomini anche è stata la mia prima
ricetta a microonde ossia una mag cake
una torta in tazza che tutti all'interno
del microonde e in pochissimo tempo
riesce a mangiarti il problema che in
passato avevo fatto degli errori perché
l'ho messo non so che cosa fosse
successo sinceramente ma di base alla
fine sbrodolata tutto da tutte le parti
per cui a questa botta ho pensato di
cambiare leggermente la ricetta renderla
secondo me ancora più buona e con molte
meno probabilità di fallimento quando si
tratta di mangiare chi mi conosce sa che
per me esistono tre cose importantissime
la prima deve essere bono la seconda da
essere veloce perché non riesco ad
aspettare la terza e deve essere con
ingredienti facili come una quarta
abbondante abbondante quinta a me
piacciono tantissimo i dolci lo si
capisce anche dal fatto che se voi
tornate al primissimo video che ho fatto
di cucina buttata vedrete che la mia
faccia era la meta non è un problema di
obiettivo è che in questo periodo il
frigo quando eri passo vicino lo sento
tremare mi metto radiato anche perché a
breve
arriva l'estate non ne parliamo mi sono
già depresso e questa era la torta una
torta l'aria
no ragazzi tutti insieme quindi per fare
check buono ragazzi e alla nutella
io se questa qui adesso la metto sulla
suola delle vostre scarpe dovete
acciaccato la star hanno buonissime
quindi non si può sbagliare veloce e
calcolate che prendiamo questa o lei se
voglio essere più figo non lo so devo
ancora capire a seconda di spa natura
dire che questa qui è più interessante
di questa questa qui ci si può fare il
bagno a un chihuahua bellissima è
velocissima perché sbattiamo tutto qua
dentro giriamo e la infilava all'interno
di microonde semplice veramente quattro
ingredienti a parte uno che ci siamo
dimenticati e che quindi stiamo
rimpiazzando con dello yogurt perché
doveva esserci il latte gianmarco si è
dimenticato il latte abbondante dipende
dal alla grandezza della tazzina quale
la faremo questa pista graham abile
questa è chiesta mangiabile e sensi di
colpa a iosa per fare la macchia alla
nutella avrete bisogno ovviamente di
tutela zucchero a yogurt al lampone un
uovo della fera ho preso ispirazione da
the king bob
[Applauso]
4 cucchiai di farina ragazza mi spiego
non dovrebbe uscire niente non dovreste
sporcare moltissimo la cucina tra i
cucchiai di zucchero un uovo 3 cucchiai
di olio sono me dovevamo usare tipo un
olio di semi per renderlo un pochino più
leggero invece sono proprio usando
l'olio extravergine d'oliva solamente
siamo quello della macchina la ragazza
dice mettetene quanto volete quanto vi
piace quindi siamo 3 cucchiai no 3
cucchiai ma a questo punto iniziamo a
girare che dovreste andare tranquilli
chaka chaka chaka sta uscendo un molto
farinosa secondo me gurgo al parco serve
semplicemente un sacchetto
a questo punto da fuggiasco di
aggiungere il latte non ci abbiamo
aggiungiamo un cucchiaino più o meno di
yogurt mettiamo un pochino di rivalità
cremosità esatto il fatto che sia al
lampone non è nemmeno malvagio come cosa
nella sfiga in realtà una fortuna
abbiamo avuto infatti un altro pochino
beh io sto già facendo di testa mia
questo vuol dire che il fallimento è
dietro l'angolo
e poi vi fate un discipline ragazzi la
spalla riesce così sembrerete i tennisti
alfine ricetta prendetela bene bene dal
basso
vogliamo provare a farne una nella
tazzina che carina riempio questa fino a
qui
[Musica]
questa qua il mio consiglio è quello di
fare tutto all'interno di una tazza io
invece voglio fare il figo e che fatico
deve pagare sempre impegno già non hai
la stessa consistenza minuto
non sono convinto che vengono
io non ho idea di cosa non ho messo il
grembiule io ho passato questo serviva
per la preparazione della preparazione
alla certo sarà un fianco
questi sono quei momenti in cui lo fa le
cose
lasciamo altri due minuti come se lo
rifarei altre venti volte con cui può
trovare a farlo perché sono sembro io
pazzo che magari e tutti ci riescono
gianmarco cresciamo inter sono mai così
cioè dei fatto così e infine a testa
aspetta un segugio un altro minuto si
marcano ma tu non devi levi tirarla
verso l'alto madonna due fortissimi
moltissimo ma non è difficile o tirarla
in alto e sbaglia il pirata si tartaruga
guarda che non è in terribile arriva il
bello bellissimo a era già così lanciano
bayern se ne lamenta fuoco forse devi
andare
non è molto invitante
va bene a mente
non posso associarla senza il grembiule
già dato dove si sente che è una
mattonata è pesante c'è qualcosa il mio
onore
ho bisogno di un parere buono
emozionante vero no sì no no è vitale
per i messaggi nella tratta no lo
sciacquato allora italiano dedicato
schifosa non lo è ma che non ci siamo
neanche cosa va c'è un diletto e lode
franco che stona secondo me quello
yogurt precari rete nutella dentro c'è
quindi propria ma non fa ma gran della
fra il sapore è quello yogurt ragazzi
testa col latte lo yogurt e questo
davvero è suggerimento alla presente da
cosa ho detto dello yogurt
il fatto che sia al lampone non è
nemmeno malvagio come cosa per infatti
né di un altro pochino dimenticate la
buona
metteteci il latte meno farina e meno
nutella lo yogurt né microonde
se volete fare anche voi questa mezza
non esitate non esitate attaccarmi su
instagram
vi lascio al infobox tutti quanti gli
altri posti dove mi potete seguire che
potete continuare a sentirvi tutte le
genti che comunque con una vita migliore
della mia la prossima domenica sempre
alle 12 uscirà un nuovo video di cucina
buttata e fino ad allora che dire in
bocca a lupo per tutto
e vi mando un bacio ciao
ingrassate ragazzi ingrassare